hey guys cam here bringing you
terrifyingly sad news the silent hill's
has in fact been cancelled following a
second day of rumors concerning the
silent hill's project publisher Konami
has now officially confirmed that it has
terminated plans to develop the game the
corporation told Gaines Bach Konami is
committed to new Silent Hill titles
however the embryonic Silent Hill
project developed with Guillermo del
Toro and featuring the likeness of
Norman Reedus will not be continued
confirmation of the project's
termination comes weeks after it was
revealed that Hideo Kojima a director of
the project is preparing to leave Konami
power struggles between stop by Kojima
Productions and Konami had escalated to
the stage where the publisher has begun
seeking a new leadership team to work on
future Metal Gear games these
developments then raised questions about
the future for silent Hills a game which
was supposed to be directed by Kojima
and developed in partnership with famed
director Guillermo del Toro on Sunday
they'll tour was quoted as saying to
fans that his collaboration with Konami
is not gonna happen
meanwhile Konami confirmed to the
handsome people over a GameSpot that its
partnership with Norman Reedus the actor
initially signed to star in silent Hills
had expired however and perhaps
surprisingly the publisher still appears
open to the possibility of future
collaborations with both Kojima and El
Toro
it said that discussions on features
Silent Hill projects involving these two
people are currently underway and please
stay tuned for future announcements oh
and one more thing and another that
feels like rubbing salt in the
cancellation wound Konami are removing
PT the utterly terrifying and quite
wonderful playable teaser that was used
as a marketing promotion for silent
hill's
from the PlayStation Store on Wednesday
so get that while it still exists so
there you have it post your eulogies in
the comments section below and by way of
homage why not enjoy this morning's
silent hill's video that Lucy and I made
a full month ago as part of in 2 minutes
I'm sorry we can see the future
[Music]
you
[Music]